robert spencer
why the
left column the new feature at jihad
watch
well you know barry the jihad is not at
the forefront of everyone's mind right
now the jihad never goes away it's a
1400 year struggle and there is jihad
activity every day somewhere around the
world and we track it at jihad watch
still
but we also saw that there was a great a
threat to freedom
coming from the left
and
efforts to
foreclose on the freedom of speech
and other freedoms that we enjoy as
americans and so we decided to start an
ongoing feature the left column which is
on the left column at g hot watch about
the fifth column of the left
and what they're doing to erode our
freedoms often in conjunction and
collaboration with jihadist